now we find out that the White House is  asking Google's YouTube to consider  reviewing the controversial anti-muslim  film from its website to see if it  violates the terms of youth John returns  from the White House the request was  actually made on Tuesday night as that  violence was taking place but it was  only disclosed today imagine there's no  rain no play no selling win a big  functional bathroom privacy  [Music]  imagine other people dictating what we  see  you to imagine though intruders clamming  your windows he's snatchin your people  are no making people scared  and  would honey badger kid now watch this  locus takes up entry let me bachelor  care imagine how the people dictate what  we see  on YouTube you may say I'm a dreamer  situations too hostile  [Music]  I hope someday they'll join us and the  world  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you